قالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بان فلسطينيا
اطلق النار على قوه من الجيش الاسرائيلي
المتواجدين قرب دوار دير شرف شمال غرب
نابلس في الضفه الغربيه حيث قامت قوات
الجيش بتحييد المنفذ ولم تقع اصابات في
صفوف الجيش معنا من دير شرف شمال غرب
نابلس مراسل الجزيره ليث
جعار ليث قربنا اكثر من ملابسات ما
جرى
نعم قبل قليل وصلت نجمه داوود الحمراء الى
حاجز دير شرف شمال غرب مدينه نابلس حيث
كان هناك اطلاق نار على شاب فلسطيني بزعم
محاولته تنفيذ عمليه اطلاق نار نحو جنود
جيش الاحتلال هنا نرصد في هذه الصوره
تواجد لاليات الاحتلال العسكريه والجيش
المنتشر بشكل كامل على حاجز دير شرف حيث
اغلق الحاجز اغلق الاحتلال كافه
الحواجز المؤديه الى مدينه نابلس تحديدا
من المنطقه الغربيه على واقع هذه هذه
العمليه ومحاوله اطلاق النار صوب جنود جيش
الاحتلال وفقا لجيش الاحتلال فانه اكد
محاوله فلسطيني اطلاق النار
صوب جنود الاحتلال المتواجدين على هذا
الحاجز لكن لم يوقع اي اصابات فبالتالي
بادر الجنود باط اطق النار نحوه بشكل
مباشر ما ادى حتى هذه اللحظه طبعا ضمن
المعطيات الاوليه وضمن ما
يخرج من قبل الاحتلال تحديدا فان الاحتلال
قد عمد على تحييد هذا الشاب لكن لا يوجد
اي معلومات واضحه حول مصير الشاب حتى هذه
اللحظه اقل من نصف ساعه على هذه ال هذا
التصفيه وهذه العمليه هنا على حاجز دير
شرف حيث هرعت اليات الاحتلال العسكريه من
كافه المعسكرات المحيطه في مدينه نابلس
ووصلت الى هذا الحاجز حيث اغلقت الحاجز
واعتدت على الفلسطينيين المتواجدين هنا
طبعا هذا الحاجز الذي يربط مدينه نابلس ب
مدن شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله طول كرم
وجنين يحاول الاحتلال منذ السابع من
اكتوبر عرقله حركه الفلسطينيين ومنعهم من
التنقل عبر هذا الحاجز قوات الاحتلال لا
تزال متواجده في في هذه المنطقه والشاب لا
يزال ملقى على الارض ونجمه داوود الحمراء
تتواجد حتى هذه اللحظه في هذه ال في هذا
الموقع وعلى ما يبدو انهم سيحاولون في هذه
اللحظات اخذ الشاب الى جهه مجهوله حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يوجد اي معلومات واضحه عن مصير
الشاب تحديدا وما جرى بشكل اساسي داخل هذا
الحاجز لكن وفق
لكلام وحديث الاحتلال والاعلام العبري
فانه يؤكد محاوله فلسطيني اطلاق النار صوب
جيش الاحتلال المتواجد على هذا الحاجز
فبادر الجيش باطلاق النار عليه ما ادى الى
اصابته
وبدات بالفعل يعني وصول بعض الاليات
العسكريه اضافيه الى هذا الحاجز وسط
الانتشار المكثف لجيش الاحتلال والاعلان
عن منطقه حاجز دير شرف نقطه عسكريه مغلقه
من قبل جيش الاحتلال كما تشاهدون الان
جنود الاحتلال يحاولون
يعني ارسال رسائل لكل متواجده هنا
بالابتعاد
عبر الاسلحه وتوجيه الاسلحه نحو
المتواجدين في هذه المنطقه انتشار واسع
لجيش الاحتلال حتى هذه اللحظه على الحاجز
بالتزامن مع استمرار هذا محاوله اخذ
الشهيد ومصادره جثمانه وربما حتى هذه
اللحظه ع الاقل وفقا لجيش الاحتلال فانه
تم تصفيته شكرا لك ليث جعار كنت معنا من
دير شرف في
نابلس